actually on that we should probably
explain what william does yeah yeah what
do you what do you do on your youtube
channel uh
yeah how would i describe it yeah
because you make such bizarre things
yeah when a random person asks you or a
family member who you don't really i i
honestly genuinely don't know how to
explain it because i used to say like
science but we just we're doing a video
about oyster farming
right you are kind of science involved
yeah but it's like not it's the angle
isn't i don't dude i don't know
yeah no
the engineering doesn't work the guy who
is generally does engineering which
apparently you guys are also
mechanical we're both yeah and you do
youtube your parents happy
i i got the degree so they were like
they were like all right if you [ __ ] up
you got the degree i didn't care that
you're
throwing it in the trash right now i
paid for it they didn't pay for it oh
they have no say that
they they were kind of like just because
you know i was doing youtube while i was
in that's that's definitely the 100 the
right way to do it oh yeah i kind of
told them i was like hey i think i'm not
gonna do engineering yeah i'm gonna try
this youtube thing out and they were
like are you gonna finish the degree i
was like yeah and they were like all
right do whatever you want yeah yeah i
finished a degree got a job and then
after about two and a half no three
three and a half years of doing the job
i was like i kind of hate this right now
kind of i kind of want to just do
youtube what's what's your background
same mechanical you should you go to
mechanical engineering major and
electrical minor oh okay oh so we both
have mechanical yeah i hated mechanical
yeah i mean it's i feel like people
don't really know engineering is when
they go into it and they see they see
someone like me who like like i like
building stuff yeah and like ah
engineering is like building stuff and
then you go to school and it's like not
building stuff
like because i think one time we spoke
about on the podcast how we didn't
really use that at greece but then it's
kind of like it's it's kind of
hard to really take that as like um like
a whole because obviously we're a very
isolated group of people right who
didn't use their degree saying oh it's
useless and it's really easy to say that
yeah it's i think it's complicated
because it's like it's not useless
but okay who do you what would you do i
did uh what did i either i'm like you
didn't do
no i i did uh i t like design computing
so it's like even if you're not
doing it work you probably have done
stuff in regards to youtube that
involved some of the items i mean i
learned how to video edit through my
yeah yeah and like audio engineering
stuff like that right so you learn
skills outside of actually getting a job
as an engineer because like if you get
an engineering degree you're like you're
not ready to go work as an engineer like
you have to go somewhere and you're
gonna cost that you have any money
because that's like this useless little
blob and they try to form you into like
actually doing real constructive work
yeah and so going to school is just kind
of like you know teaching you
some maths
and then some like just i don't know
maybe work ethic or or problem solving i
did find like the mindset that it taught
was very helpful yeah i mean i think
like one of the reasons engineering is
such a good course just in general is
the problem-solving aspect i mean that's
that's an aspect everyone will use in
their lives and it's about understanding
a system and how to kind of like find
your way around the system i mean
regardless i do use my degree in my job
because that's basically youtube in a
nutshell yeah trying to figure out the
algorithm and how and how to like make
content that appeals to an algorithm
that's a problem that's a problem
yeah and you know
there's some people who get way more
into the analytical side of youtube i
noticed i've talked to a lot of science
youtubers and you guys are constantly in
the analytics tab there's a level that's
like good in a level that's bad yeah and
i think some of the science youtubers go
way too far to the point where they
start kind of not quite understanding
like it's a little bit too robotic and
yeah it's like blame the algorithm as
opposed to maybe have a more artistic or
like empathetic approach of like why
would somebody be emotionally invested
whenever i'm doing it right right and
it's just numbers numbers numbers and
it's like well that's probably not a
good road to go down yeah
i don't look at it at all because it
just stresses me out yeah i i have
stopped looking at it yeah i don't look
at it i don't really read comments
either i read like the top three or four
yeah yeah and i'm like nice yeah nice
yeah i tried to check mine about a week
after the upload because at least at
that point like the honeymoon period is
gone and i could as like you can look at
it rationally yeah i can i can as
rationally look at this as possible yeah
like it's a problem-solving perspective
right like exactly it's not gonna help
to read a bunch of crap so i'm going to
figure out how can i use people's
feedback as constructively as possible
exactly exactly did you enjoy doing your
engineering degree while you were there
or i did i learned a lot like i learned
a lot about microprocessors which is the
electrical miner because it's like
not doing anything electrical it's it's
like witchcraft dude you can like if you
know how to use a computer that has i
can like talk to the outside world which
is basically microprocessors water
computers a little bit funky i mean you
still can't but you can do anything like
you can literally like the instant you
like you can write some code and it
turns a light on it's like oh my god
like
i think that's what i
didn't really enjoy about doing just
mechanical was that you never really got
that try try try something and get
feedback it was always like
here is a concept of how uh an aerofoil
would
react in this you please use the
aerofoil table which tells you
everything and use the number it's so
expensive to actually bring that into
the real world mechanical stuff and i
understand that and it's just kind of
like ah damn it i kind of thought we'd
do stuff yeah but i mean i don't know
maybe your school just sort of sucked we
didn't do stuff either but like that's
kind of i feel like every time i explain
anything to people like the school is
not going to teach you to like pick up a
tool no
they're going to do the analytical stuff
and for electrical engineering maybe or
computer science like you can actually
do things because it's free it's well
free it's cheap yeah mechanical stuff is
like oh you got to use the you know mill
or 3d printer or this and even if it's
not like actually expensive the sort of
time required is like expensive so
that's what i didn't like about
electronic electrical engineering which
is we didn't get to use any cool stuff
you know
i'm talking as a triple e major because
uh
i was always jealous of you know
mechanical engineers or aerospace
engineers because they always talk about
you know oh yeah i was in the wind
tunnel doing all this course [ __ ] and
i'm like i just didn't go in the window
yeah i was like
yeah i was like i was in a [ __ ] lab
just like [ __ ] writing code i know i
like turned on and that was it and i'm
like i'm like you guys are doing all the
cool [ __ ] you're spending so much time
just doing cad models and i [ __ ] hate
what is that
it's like when you build the thing in
like and i understand why because it
literally is just engineering like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's you do that
for everything but yeah oh my god was
this mind-numbing doing it and i was bad
at it i couldn't visualize things in
like a 3d space that's hard it's really
hard so i was like this is this is
miserable and
there was some other stuff that i like
i i didn't do it because i was too busy
doing youtube um so i i started doing
youtube about
second year of so in the uk we do three
years not four okay
five and a half
[Music]
yeah normally it's like a bachelor's or
before right it's supposed to be four
years so in the uk it's three okay um
so second year in i started doing
youtube so my free time was gone but
there was this thing that they did where
every single university and like um some
of them in the uk and some in europe
could build a formula one car oh yeah
yeah okay
here they call it fsae yeah
and so basically any anyone people from
the engineering people can just all come
together and build this car yeah and
they got to actually use all the tools
they got to build things you got
experience with it well that sounds fun
and i was like why did no one tell me
about that
i would have liked love to have like
actually got hands on experience your
school kind of sounds like my school a
little bit yeah where it's just it's
like very there's not a whole lot of
money i mean i don't think they're broke
but they just don't invest the money
into like creating you always hear mit
mit is like filled with clubs and
communities and stuff and that's like
it's so many smart talented people come
out of there because not the education
is better but the experiences are yeah
yeah i think it's the moment you're
my at least for me my lectures or
classes were done i was gone yeah there
was no incentive oh my gosh yeah i'm the
same incentive exactly for me to stay
on the campus and do anything else
because there was no other clubs
the only other like clubs that were even
related to my field were like i don't
know weird stuff that were just very
very very niche yeah that i was like
my only incentive was to just go to the
nearby uni bar and just get [ __ ]
that was nothing would you have joined a
club that was like relevant to your
field if you have the option if there
was a chance that we'd get hands-on do
some stuff i would gladly do it yeah
like if i could use a
cad model and maybe actually get to
print something or oh my god that
picture would be awesome it would have
been like oh okay so i can make
something that actually look at it and
understand why yeah i i i built it like
this and i try again but i understand
that it's expensive
like nowadays it's not and so they
probably do have them but like even like
relatively expensive like
a printer from you know five ten years
ago like you could still get something
that worked that would be cheap you know
like the cheapest plywood they wouldn't
even like let us do like the laser cut
out like this i would cost like one
cents a sheet or something stupid i
don't know i don't know i just kind of
wish there was more chances to get more
involved and
and get to
whatever you learned kind of
visualize it or put something out there
so you can be like oh okay yeah like
something tangible yeah yeah yeah i
don't know let's just start connecting
the dots it's like if i do this work i
get this thing like i describe
everything as tools like math is a tool
yeah you don't have to enjoy using the
tool but you are like excited when you
use the tool to make something happen
like you know i i've used calculus i
think like once in my entire life
actually and it was literally for like
making a motor speed up and slow down so
i could like generate the acceleration
of it and it was like
like holy [ __ ] finally i used this yeah
exactly and i never did it again and i'm
okay with it but it's like you know you
could do it i know i could do it yeah i
understand it a little bit better and it
was like that felt so good and it's like
did i enjoy doing it like i've been
doing a bunch of stuff recently to uh
trying to build a ct scanner mm-hmm yeah
like the like a
360 x-ray basically yeah yeah and it's
like i don't really like doing math but
there is nothing more exciting than like
writing some code that has like the math
you wrote and it works and it works and
it's just like
i
i feel like seeing that final product
and seeing that final effect makes it so
worth it because if everything's just
theoretical you're just like well this
is just [ __ ] numbers no return like
if i wanted to do this i'd be a
mathematician you know yeah but like
my university had one cool project which
was like if you do triple e and bristol
university i hope it's still a thing in
the third year we had this thing called
a buggy project where
um basically every you you know your
class will get split up into teams
so it was a group project but everyone
had to do like some part of it so yeah
everyone had to do some part of it and
we had like a buggy that we basically
had to program and amazed that the buggy
had to navigate a small car yeah yeah
like it's like a small like a small rc
car kind of that kind of deal and it had
to like program to run itself around
this maze and hit certain checkpoints
and get to the end in as efficient and
efficiently as efficient as possible and
that was the only fun thing i ever did
on the course because it was like a cool
thing that we all came together for and
we could actually see the final result
of our hard work instead of just you
know doing a model or doing you know
modeling some stuff on a computer or
some [ __ ] like yeah i work with other
people and it's like like if you can
trust these people and they do their
thing and i trust you know myself and my
teammates when you put it together and
it works exactly
but like i feel like the problem with i
feel like that kind of thing needs to be
integrated in the course because
i know myself and if there was some cool
thing that you could have done with your
course that was extracurricular activity
in university i wouldn't [ __ ] sign up
for it
i know i wouldn't have yeah i would have
been too late maybe not in my third year
because i was already way too invested
in youtube right yeah yeah exactly but i
think there are a lot of people that
would though yeah oh definitely there's
a lot of people in that middle ground
who
maybe do a specific course and i think
this happens a lot in engineering where
they're in that middle group where
they're like okay
they they're doing engineering they have
an interest in it but also there's
nothing really keeping them like super
super invested right yeah and if you
could just kind of capture that kind of
middle group people and push them
towards hey look you can you can
actually make stuff and make a
difference i think a lot of people don't
even know that they would be interested
in it yeah until you sort of like if you
open that door if you sort of connect
the dot between here you made a cad
model and then you printed it and you're
just like yeah oh yeah
you know it's almost like it's like
stifling a kid who's interested in
something where it's like you know a kid
is like oh i want to learn about this
and the parents like no and it's like
for 150 bucks you could have bought them
like a lego set or something like that
and that would have like inspired this
lifelong you know like learning
obsession yeah yeah like think of how
cheap that is you know like like a few
tens of dollars with a school like
that's an investment yeah for like
universities i mean
they have lots of money yeah they
totally don't want to they don't want to
hire the people that are required to get
people excited about stuff you know it's
like oh we have a machine shop but
nobody can use the tools because you're
going to kill yourself